une exposition avec des photos réalisées
par vincent mon gorges est porteuse de
messages pour dénoncer lutter contre les
stéréotypes et ouvrira la réflexion sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
dans le cadre de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
de la semaine sur l'égalité et la parité
la bibliothèque universitaire de
guyancourt a répondu présentes en
accueillant cette exposition portraits
de jeunes femmes étudiantes de
l'université paris saclay également
championne sportive dans différentes
disciplines
rugby football mais aussi lancer de
marteau
elles sont représentées avec
l'exposition victoire pour célébrer la
semaine de l'égalité 2019 victoire fait
un nom féminin et puis victoire aussi
parce qu'elles gagnent parce que c'est
des gagnants parce qu'elles se sont
surpassés elles ont également pu allier
leur vie de jeune femme tout en gardant
leur féminité également tout en
poursuivant des carrières universitaires
et en obtenant des résultats aussi haut
que des hommes ce sont vraiment de
véritables athlètes sportive au féminin
le sport féminin ne représente que sept
pour cent du volume global des
retransmissions sportives alors qu'une
majorité des français de plus de 18 ans
considère que le sport féminin est aussi
intéressant que le sport masculin
une exposition à la bibliothèque de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
à découvrir jusqu'au 27 mars